major major news that is not being
widely reported by corporate media about
Donald Trump's Trump foundation this is
his charitable organization it has been
effectively shut down by the New York
Attorney General it hasn't actually been
closed but yesterday we learned that New
York Attorney General Eric Schneiderman
order Donald Trump's personal charity to
stop all fundraising activities after it
was determined that the vile the UH
organization was in violation of state
law because they were soliciting
donations without proper authorization
to do so this was conveyed in a quote
Notice of Violation that was sent a few
days ago to the Donald J Trump
foundation the night before the
Washington Post had actually reported
that the foundation up did not properly
register with the state as a charity to
solicit money and now the Trump
foundation needs to do all sorts of
stuff to get back in good standing and
be able to resume fundraising activities
they need to provide financial audit
reports and if they don't comply they
will be considered to be a quote
continuing fraud upon the people of New
York naturally no surprise to anybody
the Trump campaign is implying that this
is all politically motivated Trump
campaign spokeswoman hope Hicks put out
a written statement and she said I love
the wording on this while we remain very
concerned about the political motives
behind Attorney General Schneiderman's
investigation the Trump foundation
nevertheless intends to fully cooperate
with the investigation uh yeah I mean
it's true New York Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman has endorsed Hillary
Clinton in the presidential race uh note
that as we've reported to you before
Donald Trump's own money hasn't even
been in this charitable organization for
a long time I believe that the last time
he donated it's either anything or
anything of significant value to to the
foundation was 2008 and since it's
basically been using other people's
money for political posturing political
gain etc it said
uh this entire thing is clearly one of
the Donald Trump asked scams that he is
involved in he is using this money to uh
take political advantage he is using
other people's money that you know I
don't know if when some of these rich
people donated to the Trump foundation
they donated thinking that the money
really was going to be used for true
charitable contributions or maybe they
donated expecting or knowing that listen
this is just a front really what this
money is used for is to get to buy
political favors to donate to Pam Bondi
in Florida to make an investigation
about Trump University go away I don't
know what the organization donors new or
expected but what I do know is there is
no evidence at all that this is a
charitable organization that is even
remotely close to being on the up and up
and now we are seeing every indication
that all of our suspicions about this
charitable foundation are absolutely
true projection once again right Trump
going on and on for weeks it's the
Clinton Foundation that's the problem
turns out that it's Trump's own charity
that has no shortlist of its own
problems send me your thoughts about
this i'm on twitter at dpac minh and the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
warby parker is offering a free five day
home try-on to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / tdps I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that
I glass industry is controlled by just a
few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing